une situation sanitaire toujours
difficile en europe mais des signaux
positifs dans certains pays
en allemagne les écoles bars restaurants
et commerces non alimentaires restent
fermées pour contrer l'épidémie de
covile 19 qui a connu une recrudescence
depuis la fin de l'année 2020 l'exécutif
allemand avait opté pour un nouveau
confinement dès le mois de décembre des
mesures qui semblent déjà porter leurs
fruits
nous ne pouvons pas rester dans ce
confinement dur tout l'hiver
notre société ne le supporterais pas
bien il n'est pas possible de se
prononcer avec certitude sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouverons le 14 février
les chiffres sont encourageants nous
observons une tendance significative à
la baisse concernant les nouvelles
infections avec des signaux optimistes
berlin peut se permettre des initiatives
solidaires envers ses alliés européens
les allemands ont notamment décidé
d'apporter leur aide au portugal ce
mercredi un avion militaire est arrivé
sur le sol portugais à bord de
l'appareil
huit médecins 18 infirmiers ainsi que du
matériel médical la pandémie qui sévit
au portugal depuis quelques semaines
vous le savez probablement tous est
clairement devenu problématique
la situation y est incomparablement plus
difficile qu'elle ne l'est ici chez nous
elle peut se développer à nouveau et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes nécessaires
là bas et nous ferons de notre mieux
une aide qui s'organise sans la
participation de la commission
européenne qui se dit néanmoins prête à
intervenir si le portugal en fait la
demande
de son côté l'italie a opté pour un
assouplissement des restrictions avec
notamment la réouverture des musées dans
le pays après presque trois mois de
fermeture mais les professionnels du
secteur restent vigilants
c'est aussi une forme de reconnaissance
de la part des autorités que des lieux
comme les musées peuvent garantir des
conditions de sécurité similaire aux
endroits que l'on considère comme de
première nécessité on ne sait pas si
aujourd'hui on assiste à une ouverture
définitive parce qu'il ya une variable
qui décide le virus dans la plupart des
régions du pays
les restaurants magasins et salons de
coiffure ont également rouvert leurs
portes un contexte d'embellie
alors que les populations de nombreux
pays européens sont toujours soumises
à des restrictions drastiques